hello i'm phil i'm evan and we have a
highly anticipated episode of odd man
out for you today
that's right a big shout out to manscape
for sponsoring this episode
manscape for the people who brought you
the lawnmower 3.0
i know what you're thinking electric
razors are annoying because the blades
get dull
but guess what manscape also has a
replenishment pack
boom which comes the new razer sign up
every few months they will send you a
new blade
to slap it on there and you'll also get
a free gift when you sign up
which is this handy dandy foot deodorant
deodorant for your foot
deodorant for your not just your foot
fill
for both feet it's just like 20 too
expensive for me evan well
funny you mention it phil simply go to
manscape.com
jubilee for 20 off plus free
international shipping apply directly at
checkout
no promo code needed well thank you so
much evan
and we hope you enjoy this episode of
odd men out
we brought together seven sorority girls
i'm in a sorority i'm an sorority i'm in
a sorority and i'm
in a sorority except everyone is a liar
like really all of them they're all
lying this
is odd man out
so my game plan going in is to get a
buddy buddy with one of the girls as
quick as possible
like yes girl i'm on your side don't
even worry about it
it's important that i like get the
specifics right because if i can give
details early then they're going to
trust me i plan on kind of diverting the
girl's attention
maybe talk more about girly things
instead of just greek life but also if i
start getting heat or anything like that
i'm going to start pulling everything
out of my back pocket because
i'm not going home the name that i chose
was marcia because it's close to martin
rachel's a character that i created now
i picked out a story for her i know all
the information about her chapter her
sorority
philanthropies state functions midday i
wrote down a bunch of notes
i got everything in here uh i also did
some research about just girls in
general in case you know they try to ask
me
questions about girls i did a lot of
research
actually for this because like this is
the first time i'm gonna be the bowl so
of course i'm gonna be like oh my god
what's going on i'm gonna have to type
like a girl maybe i'll use the
all lowercase strategy i'm gonna be in
all lowercase now
i'm gonna try and go a little over the
top with messages as far as like how i'm
reacting
i know this is my second time being
hopping out but i'm sweating
this is not good i just gotta
not say anything stupid all right let's
do this
all right round one let's go so i'm
gonna do
multiple eyes on high i'm not going to
be the person asking questions there's
no way that's happening
they'll pick up and if i just go ahead
so i'm going to ask where everyone is
from
i'm not weak mentally ah where's
everyone from
i'm in san jose i'm
from missouri state l.a but
go to school at ucsb i'm going to
capitalize but i'm not going to use
proper punctuation
sona for school oh my gosh arizona
that's where nicole's from nobody's
talking anything
that matters right now time's taken the
more it takes less sustainably
i am a man oh yeah i think they're
already answering that okay
what sorority is everyone in yeah
obvious question okay so the first
rule is you don't ask what sorority
you're in i don't know that's just a
sorority girl thing especially when i go
out
so that's kind of a red flag i think
i'll vote for katie but we'll see i'm in
kappa gamma delta pre-med sorority iowa
red hot
that's something that like that's like a
term that most coyotes use
see okay so i'm in ao pai but you gotta
do the double eyes
they'll catch that if you write out pie
they will catch them going with pi beta
phi here
nice sick ooh eat it there's an 80 pie
thank god
i was i almost chose 80 pie as my fake
sorority but thank god i didn't
because nicole would have just ripped me
a new one
what class am i in epsilon new
loser class were you in a new like
chapter
okay so i'm in the gamma zai chapter
i've saw new alpha thai
this is so interesting what i don't know
dude i feel like an op right now like i
feel like they can they're gonna sniff
me out is your chapter founded
i feel like this should be a pretty
common question
everyone should know this in an org that
you're in so for instance phi mew is
1852. seems really old i don't know
i don't know the number exactly
sorry okay so she means like
the chat just say some random random one
18.95 that seems okay
period okay this is i think like
1895 isn't too far off from the numbers
that they have 1892
1851 oh i can't spell we have six
founders overall
my big day was girls girls
girls damn it damn it damn they're not
answering my question i freaked up
uh out of this world what was my theme
what was my big day theme and they like
raced home
this girl wants to go into the founders
i hope we can just skip past that just
move it to the side
because uh i'm just gonna give a random
name
it was breaking records
i love my good day okay nicole
trying to trying to not be a mole here
like i didn't want to leave out the
founders question just because i didn't
want to get anyone suspicious so i
brought it back in
and i said that mary mary martha are the
three founders of buy me a sorority
which is very true
it's on their uh fine mew website
oh god i made something up hopefully
they uh hopefully they didn't notice
or see you right through me
what's everyone's philanthropy oh bet
baby bet
oh what is our philanthropy ronald
mcdonald
oh did i give myself away on that one
[Music]
oh wait okay she named him she named him
i think only like three people
said they're they're founders did they
three mary mary martha
three thunders dude no one's gonna
suspect me and if they do
screw that that's stupid when people
started talking about philanthropy
all the other sorority girls were able
to just you know type freely whereas i
was like
having to think about it a little bit
and it delayed my answers i think
my downfall was the founder's question i
think i survived that round
um there were other girls who didn't
talk that much i threw in some messages
here and there i didn't want to take
control of the chat too much
i really have nobody to vote for like
nobody said anything to us but i think
i'm gonna go with nikita
sorry girl i just don't wanna be the
first one to like be voted out to be
honest
i think i'm gonna vote for nicole
stephanie that's a lot of questions and
i gotta be the person to ask questions
that way i don't think it's me
stephanie she's an op that was so
specific she gave them ammunition
for them to get on my heels i think i'm
going to have to vote for kate
she might be the person to vote me out
in the later rounds
and i kind of just want to get the
strongest person out
nicole seems a little sus to me just
because like
ronald mcdonald house charity come on
and she said i love
bid day do you want to be the mole i
think i'm gonna
put nikita she didn't talk like a girl
i guess i swear if i did all this work
to get kicked out immediately
i'll be upset a three-way tie
nicole nikita and stephanie oh no
you guys are gonna have 30 seconds now
to type out a
paragraph which states your case and why
you do not deserve to be voted out right
now
this is not good at all this is not good
i am scared
i am so i love my sorority oh my gosh i
can't type oh my gosh i can't type
hold on not okay i'm not there's no way
i'm not getting out right now i don't
think i should
be kicked out so really i screwed up
i screwed up so bad oh my god
oh i said i said i'm a girl why did i
say that obviously i'm a girl
all right so everyone other than them
now gets a chance to re-vote
let's face i know they're all telling
the truth but if i had to pick one that
i thought was lying
i'd probably pick nicole i'm still gonna
vote for stephanie
that's gonna be my downfall if she stays
in this competition so kate
when you watch this i think you're the
strongest person in this chat
and stephanie has a garbage
garbage case also i'm a girl
i'm sorry i'm sorry stephanie you're
probably a really good person
it was just really bad all right so the
first
person voted out is going to be
stephanie
bye stephanie everyone was everyone was
talking about why they joined the
sorority i should have done that
instead i'm just talking about like oh i
did everything correctly and then to top
it off i say
and i'm a girl yeah i messed up big time
i hold it
under pressure i cracked like a like a
fragile
fragile uh glass
i don't know i'm supposed to return home
my sorority after this
okay so i know i answered it a bit but
why did you rush to your sorority
i gotta think why um okay so they're
asking
why did you join us writing um
i joined because i was
on um my
cheer team in high school
and i really wanted a sense
of community and support on
such a large campus
all right so i'm going to drop a legacy
card i don't think anyone has said that
yet so i'm going to say that
that's hard to talk and like all right
i'm saying i rushed
because you know i love the girls made a
huge connection with everybody
and let's say let's say i have reading
problems
when i was little what are some of your
favorite tg themes
what's that let's just skip over that
so a tg is a themed gathering it's like
when a fraternity
pairs up with a sorority for a night and
they like have an event together
this k girl she's coming in late you're
too late
we sniffing you out
i'm gonna keep the country broken y'all
do blind dance
all right big question can you answer
once is what one of my one of my
sorority friends told me
they only wear white to initiation i
mean i could keep talking about our
philanthropy but okay
kate said big question can you all
answer at once
okay thank you marsha um
what color did you wear to initiation i
don't know if she's talking about
initiation or like
just getting like pinned in because
they're two different things
and one of them is very secret which i
have no clue of the first two said white
and then i was thinking that the rest of
them were gonna say white and that was
gonna be the thing that they do
across all sororities and then this girl
said burgundy they're going to sniff the
boats
both of us out kate said every sorority
here wears white
i'm i'm throwing all the suspect on
marsha and nikita right now
um okay i'm not gonna ask that big
little reveal i think i'm in the clear
so far oh nikita
nikita says oh we didn't have ours yet
because of corona
but she said burgundy
every sorority here wears white i'm
saying
i saw some sororities on campus had
designer brands
oh no i got no notes on that one
they had designer brand big little
reveals okay we have like one minute
um and nobody's really typing they asked
big little reveal theme
and i simply don't know the answer to
that i don't even know what a big little
reveal theme would be
okay i'm just gonna skip that question
really quickly i think i'm good i
honestly think i'm doing i'm really good
right now
barbie all right you know i'm an
upperclassman
i had my big little reveal damn it just
like i'm not cheating
because i talked to my story friends
like oh so i said where are using
zoom i totally mistyped that every story
girl wears
white to their initiation that's a thing
how am i supposed to know that i don't
even have initiation i think i'm gonna
go
after nikita just because she she said
the color of her initiation and then
she's like oh wait we didn't have
initiation
i'm gonna vote for nikita just because
she said burgundy
i think i'm gonna vote for michaela kate
kate is speaking a lot
she's being very specific nitpicky i
don't like that
because then they're gonna sniff me out
and she's gonna be asking the wrong
questions
unfortunately kay you must be terminated
i'm gonna be voting for
marsha because she was the only one that
was said blue but i said burgundy so
it's probably gonna be a tie between me
and her
kate was really coming for our next
though she said every sorority here
wears white and i don't know if that's
like a
question or if she was just really
saying like you guys wore blue and
burgundy like
liars there's been another tie it's
between nikita
and kate why am i good viewing that's
not good what did i do
no please no oh no
no i thought i was doing so good did i
alrighty did i chill thank you guys
it's just because i feel like nikita's
gonna get the boot i'm gonna vote for
kate
i don't know why not yeah i'm still
gonna vote kate
all right so i'm gonna actually be
voting for kate this time
our next person eliminated is
kate oh my god
like basically only asking questions the
entire time so i probably should have
laid low the second round
and then what sealed my fate is i
couldn't type or think of anything for
the life of me
i just got murked
all right we got three minutes um how
about you but being put on a vote twice
in a row isn't scared
really scary
my mouth i'm gonna hit her with the
little mao mao
um what are you guys into marcia wants
to know
i'm asking good questions here because i
already have what i'm gonna say
and then if they bring the composition
somewhere else and
make mood boards line dance line dance
is a sorority thing at least it is at
florida state
i mean i love to surf make mood boards
um what other quirky things are there
if they did line dance i don't sound
like an idiot like if they don't do this
anywhere else i'm kind of
kind of screwed the pooch on that one
but so i'm gonna ask
if uh their sororities a local or
national uh sorority this is actually a
pretty big one
oh we're just talking oh they thought i
was talking about hobbies
okay ucsb i like to surf that makes
sense right um so basically now we're
getting into the girl talk
uh oh dude they think i i guess
it might just be a florida state thing
okay so now they're just talking about
line dancing yes the ocean is literally
two minutes from my apartment
beauty oh okay yeah the ocean is already
two minutes for my apartment
but i want the little twinkly lights um
or this i'm gonna put the star hahaha
i'm gonna go with the hashtag charge i
feel like my typing style is good
i've gone the lowercase round i'm gonna
try to play on to this one just because
i asked a question and we're kind of
rolling on now about
just girl talk i i seem so legit right
now
so legit i love this these mutual
connections
let's go let's go marsha let's go it's
our job
let's go charge up brah i can't
spell what's going on wrong was your
initiation
i'm gonna say ooh
it's so hard to type on my laptop with
long nails
i'm going to say girl i feel your pain
keep having
oh my gosh i can't having to retype
everything arises the 81 constantly was
i'm moved about nails i don't know
ignore it though this initiation
question
could hurt me but i'm gonna wait
okay is this the av yeah ours is the uv
light processing
is moved to a virtual platform halfway
i said i almost broke a nail the other
day i got so frustrated when i was
typing my essay
the charge thing is what stuck out to me
it's like workout group all girls
a regular dude would not know about that
me michaela we're homies now
because uh you know charge up charge up
let's get rid of nikita everyone's
suspicious of her already
i'm probably just gonna vote for nikita
i'm gonna go with nikita i think if we
got her out this round we might just
conclude the game and say you know what
no more moles i believe you guys
nikita is gonna be gone only because the
last two rounds
people were suspicious i think rachel
was the most suspicious one because she
did
line dancing i swear to god if i'm voted
out during
the person voted out is nikita damn it
damn i'm a terrible mole
i was already put on the spot literally
twice if you're put on the spot
then like everyone else is like
incentivized to like you know go for all
that
i am satisfied with the fact that i
can't pass two rounds
give me a thumbs up if you want to
continue and a thumbs down if you think
you've caught them all and want to end
the game now
okay i'm getting a majority thumbs down
i'm putting my thumbs down oh my god all
right
let's go i am so
sorry y'all they're about to be mad oh
man i can't believe i didn't even think
i was gonna win it
whoever's the mall reveal when you feel
ready to do so
[Music]
nice
[Music]
everyone's a dude everyone's a dude what
has happened y'all played that oh my
gosh
wait so are you all in the fraternity
delta kai missouri state
kappa sigma california omicron omega
chapter
high side fsu so i'm in phi delta
epsilon pre-medical fraternity
i thought it'd be really cool for me to
join in because like i'm in a co-ed
fraternity so like you know
boys girls that who was the person who
said
i'm a girl
that's my bad i messed up big time i was
like i'm a girl so
i thought it made sense in my mind i was
like wow a girl's really
like trying to get away with that well
you guys are all gonna
get 50 bucks as a participant
[Applause]
i need that money for rent there's been
a ton of people asking for this episode
for a while yeah
like i i always see this in like the
comments and i'm like um
okay definitely
all right guys take care all right
thanks guys
everyone was a dude i have no words
i have no words i'm so mad i don't
we were all surprised we all we did not
expect this whatsoever
beyond the comments kyle you're like how
did you not think it was like yeah
awesome tick tock famous steve wears
pants follow me shameless plug
moral to story men are trash